he's Richard Roeper Chicago Sun Times
columnist movie critic he was given the
early access to the last dance the
10-part ESPN docu-series about the 1990
bowls that premieres this Sunday so is
this the Bulls documentary or the
Michael Jordan documentary Richard well
Dan you were there at the time and you
that was always the question are we
talking about the Chicago Bulls in the
1990s or Michael Jordan he dominates the
documentary the same way he dominated
every conversation about the Bulls in
the 1990s every interview even when you
know they're talking to Steve curd and
it's Robin or Berkeley or anybody else
they're usually talking about Jordan so
he definitely the focal point of this
interview and as you well know Michael's
not always been the most candid and
forthcoming and you know honest guy when
it comes to interviews he you know he
always kept it kind of a close guard so
it's really refreshing to see him open
up on so many levels in this documentary
did they need to do ten parts does it
feel like it stretched out just to
stretch it out for ten ten parts if it
were only about the Bulls on court I'd
say okay even a team that won six NBA
titles doesn't need ten hours but when
you look at the off-court
soap opera that went on through the 90s
from Michael's gambling problems to the
tragic murder of his father to Jerry
Krause saying organizations win
championships not only players to the
Dennis Rodman circus to Michael retiring
in the middle his peak to play baseball
there's so much material there Dan I
mean it actually doesn't feel like it
stretched out at all how deep do they go
into Jordan's gambling it's not it's not
a huge part of a documentary you know
they do talk about it you know the
infamous interview where he did himself
no favors with Ahmad Rashad where they
kept the sunglasses on and said I don't
I don't have a gambling problem I have a
competition problem you know they they
don't shy away from it but it's they
don't spend a whole episode on it either
is there one of those oh my gosh moments
in this documentary
I don't know if there's an oh my gosh
moment you know it's not as if we're
learning a ton of stuff that you know
the hardcore sports fan didn't know
before it's but to me the most
interesting thing Dan is to see these
guys in present day Michael Jordan Isiah
Thomas Larry Bird still having that
competitiveness you know and there's
some of the favorite moments for me for
the documentary is when the filmmakers
don't hand Jordan a tablet where he can
see an interview with someone that was
done for the documentary so they play
him Isaiah Thomas trying to rationalize
why the Pistons did shake hands with the
Bulls after the 1991 he's during the IBA
Eastern Conference Finals the Jordan
looks at it and shakes his head and then
in kind of an expletive Laden way calls
Isaiah quite a few names and says he's
not buying any of this guy's crap I saw
where Bill Laimbeer was on ESPN I think
yesterday and he said LeBron is the
greatest basketball player of all time
not Michael Jordan so these guys are
taking this to their graves that that
competition that that doesn't dissipate
you know maybe it gets put on a back
burner but it's always going to be there
and I can imagine mike holds grudges
Mike invented grudges he created
crutches and you go right he constantly
thought they talked about that quite a
bit as you know he would try he had to
find a reason to get fired up for games
so you know if Jerry Krause at one point
said he really liked Dan Majerle then
the next time i early
guarded Jordan was gonna hit 50 points
against him you know any little
perceived light and he actually says you
know the famous kind of you know fist
pumping waving thing he did after
hitting the shot against the Cavaliers
he said that was directly aimed at the
Chicago beat writers all of whom had
predicted the Cavaliers would win the
series and he says again at this you're
right this is a guy now in his fifties
if he goes bleep you bleep urge you
didn't believe in us that's that was for
you Jordan had a kind of pre-emptive
quote here before this is released this
weekend saying I come off as maybe not a
good guy in this I'm paraphrasing
basically saying you know I pick on
teammates in fact Steve Kerr's on with
this next hour and we know what happened
with do they address the punch when he
punched Steve Kerr in practice yes in
great detail and the fact that he would
pick on you know you might you might
remember this he same as we would call
it will Purdue will Vanderbilt because
he said he wasn't tough enough to be
named after a Big Ten team but he would
heal you
let's face it the guy was pretty good he
was kind of a Don Rickles of practice
but you know did you know the Bulls
practices were you know famously intent
and he would pick on somebody like a
Scotty Burrell who came out of college
as a top rate player but was a super
nice guy and Michael would just pick on
him
pick on him pick on him and you see guys
like Burrell and Judge boots were and a
lot of you know kind of secondary
players saying no he wasn't a good guy
at all he was not nice at all
but Jordan says I never asked anybody
else to do what I wouldn't do when it
comes to working out staying on the
court playing tougher so he made
everybody around him better we're
talking to Richard Roeper the great
movie critic columnist Chicago sun-times
Rodman more interesting on the feet on
the court or off the court considering
he was married to Carmen Electra he
dated Madonna everything else that went
along with Rodman being on the sidelines
of a game one day talking to a bunch of
beat writers and they're like what is
this man says it really didn't Madden
I'm like she's right behind you right
come to Chicago for the game you know
the antics to me one of the most
fascinating things at one point in their
final run in the 97 98 season drivers
said he just wasn't motivated he needed
a vacation and Phil and Michael
unilaterally decided let him have 48
hours of Vegas he went to Vegas on a
vacation Carmen Electra is in this
documentary as well as you I didn't know
he had a game that weekend could you
imagine now in this day and age a player
in a coach thing yeah
take 48 hours off and Jerry Rice said I
didn't know about it either until I saw
them in the news that he was in Vegas
two stories that now have a lot of
stories some that I can't tell but some
have to do with the Bulls
but one was Rodman had a birthday party
at a place called the crowbar and I
remember going in and it was the second
floor and he had it all to himself
and he always thought I was Craig Sager
he forever he did say hey what's up
Sager and I go hey Dad I just got to the
point I answered for Craig Sager if you
went to the bar to get a beer
there were if the bar was full of
kamikazes so there's no place for
anything else other than if you went to
the bar you had to do a shot and then
Dennis would do a shot and he had a
Chicago police uniform or shirt on and I
remember I left at 4:00 in the morning
he had a game the next night so Rodman
was there when I left the crow bar I get
to practice they have a shoot around in
like a 10 o'clock or 11 o'clock I see
Jud Busch ler and Steve Kerr and ago
here he ran into Dennis last night I go
is he here and he goes oh yeah yeah and
he's down at the other end running
around like a madman and I think he had
18 rebounds that night in the game and
the other one was I'm at a game against
Seattle in the NBA Finals and I'm
uncovering Seattle's huddle for ESPN
Radio and I see the conversation that
that they were having with like they
were arguing in the huddle you know
Jordan was yelling and and everybody was
yelling and Phil just was standing there
Phil finally goes and he said something
like shut up or whatever and then
everybody stopped and then he basically
said shut up so Michael can tell you
what we're going to do and I was just
like oh my god the other time Dennis was
playing in a game ball goes out of
bounds Prince's in the front row and he
goes over and he starts to talk to
Prince and Prince doesn't acknowledge
him and Prince's bodyguard says you have
to talk to me and then I tell Prince
what you're saying
so tennis so Dennis is talking to his
bodyguard who then turns to Prince
because Dennis wants to know if Prince
wants to go out after the game I was
told like they're just so many things
that have
with those and when's the last time you
remember a team that everybody loved
unless they were facing your team
these guys were true like Golden State
we turned against Golden State after a
while you know the Patriots you turn you
get all these teams you just go I love
him or hate him the Bulls had a
fascination that didn't turn other
people off which is amazing no you're
absolutely right but you know remember
when when Jordan came back and went to
Madison Square Garden and there were
signs on Broadway New York welcoming
Jordan back and there's a great you know
segment in the documentary where the
Bulls went to Paris they're you know one
summer and the French media were going
that mean they were it was insane and
Michael where's the parade I think that
he's in Paris you know so it really was
you know and I know you know the younger
posters are like oh there's a lot of
great teams like the Patriots but then
what you're saying is true the universal
love and respect that Magic Johnson
gives a beautiful quote the documentary
where he's like losing to the Bulls was
still an honor you know to Michael
Jordan and the Bulls that was a
different level you didn't feel bad he
held your head up high if he lost the
Chicago Bulls at that time and I still
look back on the role that Jerry Krause
played and like who was more responsible
for the Bulls being great tonight and
and I don't know if it came down to Phil
versus Jerry Krause or Michael versus
Jerry Krause but Jerry Krause the GM you
know helped build the team and he was
going to disassemble it take the
wrecking ball to it how do they address
that why was it the last dance why
didn't they stick around and try to make
one more go of it yeah that's a central
theme of the documentary and I do agree
with you I think you know Jerry Krause
and Steve can talk about this deeper but
he was his own worst enemy but he I
think he is unfairly maligned for you
know a few comments because when you
look at what he did building those teams
you know people forget Pittman was
actually drafted by Seattle yeah but the
Bulls that orchestrated his trade for
him he found Horace Grant he always
found the perfect guy during the Pippen
were the only two guys who were on all
six of those teams he always found the
guy okay we need a veteran we're going
to get Bill Cartwright we lost
granted the magic we're gonna bring in a
rebounder a Dennis Rodman
we don't have Paxson anymore we got John
Osteen Curt yearly all he always figured
out a way to put the perfect pieces in
place he's also the guy that that
recommended the Reinsdorf that they
bring in this guy named Phil Jackson who
was in the outer outer edges of
organized basketball they brought him in
as an assistant then eventually you know
he became you know the head coach so you
know Krause you know unfortunately is
not remembered well you know and he said
the wrong things that he did he wanted
to dismantle that team probably a year
early to tell Phil Jackson before his
final year even if you go 82 and oh
you're not coming back that's insanity
because it couldn't have been monetary
reasons coated because Mike was making
about thirty million dollars a year but
yeah you know for so many years Mike was
the fourth fifth or sixth highest-paid
player on his own team he made so much
money from Nike but I I didn't
understand was it ego to say hey I can
do this with another team in another
coach or was it money
it was definitely ego it wasn't about
money it was definitely about ego about
why are these you know it happens in our
business sometimes too or a program
director doesn't understand blah blah
why the host is getting all the
attention when he built the radio
station and Gary Perry didn't laughing
he didn't know what I'm talking about
there that never happened but you know I
think unfortunately yet Jerry just you
know he he didn't get any credit you
know he and he wanted that and you're
you're absolutely right then he wanted
to you know get rid of Phil Jackson say
goodbye to Michael and start all over
again with Tim Floyd and you know and
rebuild the dynasty and we all know how
that didn't work out great stuff Richard
as always thanks for joining us we look
forward to watching it thanks Dan that's
Richard Roper